[Applaudissements]
elles ont entre 15 et 17 ans et sont 10
à défendre les couleurs de lycée jean
vilar à plaisir pour cette finale deux
académies sont représentés versailles et
créteil sur les cinq équipes en lice
seules deux pourront se qualifier aux
championnats de france
on se bat on donne tout ce qu'on a sur
certains matches à quelques erreurs mais
bon après on est là pour s'améliorer
aussi l'association sportive de rugby
féminin a été créé il ya seulement
quelques mois au lycée jean vilar
les joueuses s'entraînent une fois par
semaine cet événement permet notamment
de mettre en valeur ce sport qui se
développe de plus en plus chez les
femmes
mes filles vont moins vite c'est moins
impressionnant en termes de vitesse de
jeu par contre c'est un rugby où il ya
beaucoup plus de continuité le ballon à
la vie bien les filles arrivent à
vraiment mettre pas mal de pas mal de
rythme et de continuité dans le jeu donc
c'est un rugby qui est agréable à
regarder
c'est c'est en même temps aussi une
ambiance au sein de l'équipe qui est
vraiment chouette
on se soude on est vraiment on se parle
beaucoup et on se motive les uns les
autres et vraiment c'est ça qui nous
fait se motiver on sait que ni à nos
amis qui sont dans les gradins notre
famille des fois aussi des professeurs
des les surveillantes c'est important
pour elle c'est important pour
l'établissement elles vivent une
expérience riche et j'espère que ne font
que ne font que débuter qu'on ira
beaucoup plus loin les années prochaines
les filles du lycée jean vilar termine
sur la deuxième marche du podium
l'île de france sera représentée par
deux lycées de l'académie de créteil au
championnat de france